hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast so Tom tree made easy
obtaining reliable results with nucleic
acid measurements I'm qt or Oracle's
levers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
eppendorf eppendorf is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and sell handling in
laboratories worldwide for more
information please visit eppendorf com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
the interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or you
can submit your problem through the
green two and a button lower left I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Natasha of ice Natasha vice is a
field application specialist responsible
for the photometry product portfolio
within customer support at eppendorf AG
headquarters in hamburg germany to join
the company in 1999 and worked on
electro paraders dispensers pcr
equipment consumables as well as several
cross pneumatic projects Natasha studied
biology at the University averts Berg in
Germany for her diploma thesis she
employed a variety of molecular biology
methods investigating encoding for
variance factors in the genome of
pathogenic bacteria I will now turn it
over to Natasha for her presentation
thank you very much Judy for your kind
introduction yes Natasha welcome to
everyone and thank you for joining our
webinar photometry made easy
my presentation today will focus on the
topics photometry basics and nucleic
acid quantification regarding the letter
I would cover the introduction to the
method evaluation and troubleshooting as
well as an overview on the rug flow
together with the summary first we start
with photometric basics now which
wavelengths are used in photometry for
trauma tree bases on light which is a
kind of electromagnetic wave data in
literature variety but light having
wavelengths from 100 to 400 nanometer is
cause i trow violet the range from 400
to 700 nanometers covers the visible
light and above 700 nanometer to near
one millimeter we find infrared light as
the name suggests only visible light can
be seen as a color with our eyes wide
light like the Sun includes ultraviolet
visible and infrared light such white
light may be split into a narrow band of
wavelengths using tools like Souter or
prison this results in the so-called
monochromatic light and a photometric
measurement for most biochemical methods
are played at wavelengths from
approximately 200 up to nine hundred
nanometer different materials absorb
light at specific wavelengths this can
be shown in a photometric scan across a
large wavelength range which is shown
here by an example of the dye brilliant
blue spectrophotometry is a scientific
method which bases on the absorbance of
light by substance they are by the
underlying physical laws are used for
estimating the concentration of the
substance for this approach of peak
wavelength which means wavelengths which
maximum absorbance is choosing most
important parts of a photometer are a
light source a place place for
positioning the sample to be studied and
the detector for determining the light
intensity which is transmitted by the
samples an additional element which is
not included on this slide is a part
able to split white light into
monochromatic light in a photometer
incident light with the intensity I 0
passes through a sample the light which
is not absorbed by the sample is
transmitted and measured by the detector
the intensity of transmitted light is
termed I the ratio of I to i0 gives the
transmittance which is often expressed
as a percentage resulting in the
percentage transmittance the software of
the photometer can convert the amount of
light that that is transmitted into the
amount of light that was absorbed by the
solution the underlying formula states
that the absorbance corresponds to the
negative the cata Glauber rhythm of the
transmittance in a photometer the
detector determined the absorbance by
processing the information of incident
light intensity and never transmitted
light intensity absorbance which is
measured dependable three parameters see
spent for the sample concentration and
l4 the optical path length which is
defined by the qubit used it decry it it
describes the distance travelled by the
light epsilon is the molar extinction
coefficient which is a physical constant
of the molecule it is you it is used to
this
following its the ability to absorb
light of a specific wavelength I will
come back to this coefficient later the
number bear lore describes these
correlations and represents there by the
basis for photometry it is a combination
of the Lambert's law which states that
the absorbance of a sample is directly
proportional to the distance travelled
by the night and the beers law which
says that absorbance is proportional to
the concentration of the sample
state-of-the-art photometer includes of
the program's bathing on the reformed
laminate burn law which enable the
direct calculation of the concentration
of specific sample types why measure
absorbance instead of transmittance the
aim of spectrophotometry and biochemical
applications is to determine the
concentration of substances so why do we
prefer to express the Lambert bear law
using absorbance as a measure rather
than percentage transmittance on this
slide you see a series of samples each
of them absorb fifty percent of the
incoming light so the amount of the
original radiation passed by the first
sample is fifty percent by the second
sample is twenty-five percent and by the
third sample of 12.5 percent by plotting
the transmittance as well as the
absorbance we see that percentage
transmission leads to an exponentially
decaying curve whereas the absorbance
values which based on a logarithmic
formula result in a linear graph
we have seen that the amount of light
diminish exponentially as it travels
through the material therefore
transmittance is obviously difficult for
determination of sample concentration
since the absorbance of a sample is
defined by a logarithmic formula it is
directly proportional to the
concentration of the absorbing material
this linear relationship enables an easy
and convenient quantification of samples
in order to get feeling for the meaning
of absorbance units I put common
photometric values with corresponding
percentage transmittance rates together
on this slide you see that due to the
logarithmic formulas zero absorbance
originated from a transmittance rate of
one hundred percent an absorbance of one
is equal to ten percent light
transmittance and an absorbance of two
corresponds to one percent transmission
much higher absorbance values will not
be suitable since any further increase
in concentration will reflect only
slight changes in absorbance and the
amount of light which reaches the
detector will be too low so this leads
to the question why absorbent why the
absorbance range is reasonable in
photometry there is a linear dependency
between abnormals and concentration but
this linearity is limited by chemical
and instrumental factors the lemon bear
law is not valid for high concentrated
salads due to strong molecular
interactions and limitations are given
by stray light effects of a photometer
used dre light can be caused by scatter
or reflection of light inside the device
when reaching the detector it will
severely impact high absorbance
measurements in the line
figure the influence of different
amounts of stray light is shown by a
plot of measured absorbance values vs.
true absorbance only when those dry
stray light is available which is of
course theoretical total linearity can
be achieved the curves of measured
absorbance will start flattening the
earlier the higher the stray light
component of the photometer this means
that the concentration of high absorbing
samples will be underestimated according
to this example readings up to 1 or
perfectly linear devices with the lowest
rated rate may also give reliable values
up to 2 or 3 absorbance units besides
deviations when measuring high
absorbance the lambert bellows also
limited when very low concentrated
samples are used due to background noise
coming from electronic components of the
photometer in the environment the figure
on the right side illustrates that in
absorbance higher than 0 point 1 can be
easily distinguished from the noise
whereas this becomes more difficult with
the lower sample concentrations it has
to be considered that the percentage of
the error increases with low
concentrations and you have to decide by
yourself which error is example for your
application for being on the safe side
your values should lie between 0 point
one and one point or absorbance units
all substances of key or not absorbs
sunlight therefore we have to consider
that light is also absorbed by the cubed
and the center solvent if you want to
determine the concentration of a
substance in order to obtain the
absorbance of the sample only a blank
measurement has to be performed using
the same wavelength as well as the same
cubit and solvent prior to sample
measurement
the blank measurements at the instrument
20 which corresponds to a subtraction of
blank from sample resulting in the truth
sample value before we start with the
next chapter now I would like to ask you
to participate in our first poll which
you will see soon on the screen
so you see the result of your Paul and
we see that more than seventy two
percent of you already doing nucleic
acid quantification and a 14-percent
learn to do it I would like to go over
the next partner nucleic acid
quantification and I will introduce the
method first why quantitative leg aces
nucleic acids are isolated in order to
use them for a high variety of
downstream applications in general these
reactions require a specific amount and
a high quality for optimal performance
therefore it is crucial to evaluate the
concentration of the nucleic acids as
well as their purity after isolation
especially the presence of inhibiting
contaminants which may come from poor
sample preparation or which associated
with the difficult central matrix like
leather sole soil can lead to visible
problems extra product may be generated
during pcr analysis activity of enzymes
can be refused transfection shows low
efficiency or short wavelengths during
sequencing cannot cure an easy method to
perform quantification and quality
control of DNA and RNA is represented by
uv-vis spectrophotometer II
nucleic acid shown absorbance peak at
260 nanometer which allows for a simple
estimation of the concentration after
absorbance measurements the software of
the photometer can directly calculate
the concentration of the sample beijing
on the Lambert bear law this example
shows the measuring result of
double-stranded DNA for which the South
Pacific sector 50 micrograms per
milliliter is used on this slide I would
like to give you some more information
about parameters of the lambeth bear law
the molar extinction coefficient epsilon
is valid for specific sample types as a
specific wavelength for calculating
concentrations easily the reformatted
Lambert bellmore is used and the
reciprocal of epsilon combined with the
path length is replaced by the factor f
the underlying statement says that an
absorbance of 1 corresponds to a
concentration of 50 micrograms per
milliliter double-stranded DNA in a 10
millimeter cuvette in the table the
factors respect of the concentration at
an absorbance one are indicated for
different okay ASA types the factor is
not only influenced by the sample type
but also by the path length of the culet
when smaller cubes with one or two
millimeter path lengths are used the
factor will increase examples for
different cuba types are given in the
second table it is shown that smaller
projects are suitable for the detection
of higher concentrated sample solutions
a number of other substances can
interfere with measurements of DNA or
RNA since they also absorb light at 260
nanometer this leads to an artificial
increased result to compensate for this
purity ratios and background correction
have been developed to help eliminate
false readings potential contaminants
like proteins carbohydrates thoughts and
organic solvents show high absorbance at
230 nanometer and 280 nanometer these
wavelengths are used to calculate the
purity ratios a 260 280 280 and a 262 a
234 determining the background a
measurement at 320 nanometer or 340
nanometer is typical since nucleic acids
do not absorb in this range on this
slide some more information and most
important contaminants is given proteins
are probable contaminants after
isolation of nucleic acids they have an
absorbent speak at 280 millimeter and
additionally absorbent at 230 nanometer
is very high the presence of other
impurities like carbohydrates karabakh
salts and organic solvents is indicated
by high absorbance at 230 nanometer only
a mixture of different nucleic acid
types like DNA and RNA cannot be
distinguished in ignorance measurements
since they show the same peak at 260
nanometers this can be crucial when for
example plasmid DNA is isolated from
bacteria without rnase digestion since
ninety percent of the purified nucleic
acid
rrna the resulting calculated DNA
concentration based on deployment
measurements will lead to wrong results
due to massive overestimation since
Errol a shows higher absorbance than DNA
the real amount of DNA will be even
lowered than indicated we have seen
other slides before that contaminants
absorbing at 260 nanometer lead to fall
in creased readings tool and regarding
the absorbance range we have learned
that the evaluation of nucleic acid
concentrations lower than the microgram
per milliliter range is not appropriate
these problems can be overcome by an
alternative quantitation method the
fluorescence spectroscopy in
fluorescence spectroscopy the
fluorescence intensity of a tie that
binds to a nucleic acid is measured in
cooperated diet absorb light of their
specific excitation wavelengths and will
afterwards the mid light of a lower
emission wavelength fluorescent dyes can
react very specifically the diet pickle
green for example only burns to
double-stranded DNA and not to other
look like a so types or contaminants
upon binding the fluorescence of pickle
green increases more than 1,000 fold
which leads to a high sensitivity of the
method taking these facts together high
accuracy and nucleic acid quantitation
can be achieved
of such an experiment is not done by a
factor but using a standard curve
therefore nucleic acid standards with a
known concentration as well as the
samples are labeled with a fluorescent
dye the standards are measured in order
to generate a standard curve afterwards
the concentration of an unknown sample
is calculated by comparing the intensity
to the emitted light with a standard
curve if you compare the methods we see
that both have their advantages and
disadvantages so the decision which one
is most readable will depend on the
sample type and the application or
requirement the detection limit for
fluorescence measurements is quite low
so it enables the quantification of
highly commuted sentence additionally
the method is very specific regarding
the target molecule and therefore
suitable for mixed sample types
information on Santa curity and possible
interfering substances are only
available with absorbance measurements
which are fast and easy to perform in
which do not require expensive reagents
for sensitive downstream applications
that may be useful to perform both types
of measurements in order to achieve a
very accurate quantification in
combination with information on the
quality of the sample we come now to the
next part it refers to all who already
do nucleate asa quantification by
photometry
so the result of this par L is here and
we see that sixty-five percent of you
use only UV absorbance and
three-point-four percent already do
fluorescence measurement we're at thirty
one percent perform of course are the
two measurement methods or the following
slides I would like to present how to
analyze measuring results and in which
way troubleshooting is done therefore we
will follow this evaluation sequence by
answering the questions which measuring
range is readable which are the causes
of background in which way purity ratios
are evaluated as well as how to make
sure that repeated readings will be
stable in the part photometry basics we
had already seen the slide but shows
that very high absorbent as well as very
low absorbance is error prone the linear
range of measurements depends also on
the technical specifications of the
photometer used but in general validator
can be achieved when the readings are
between 0 point 1 and 1 absorbance
readings which are outside the linear
range are not directly proportional to
the sample concentration and this leads
to inaccurate results hi absorbance
values 3,000 stray light effects in the
photometer in order to reduce the
absorbance and hopes can be either
diluted or achieve it with a shorter
path length can be choosen low
absorbance values are influenced by
background noise for achieving better
accuracy it is recommended to
concentrate the sample or to increase
the cubic path length as possible if
only
cause of low concentrated several are
available also valuation by fluorescence
can be an alternative background is the
turbidity of the sample and it is
measured at a point of the spectrum
which is not related to the sample
absorbance for yuri spectrophotometry of
nucleic acids typical background
wavelengths are 320 or 340 nanometer
since nucleic acids will not absorb in
this range so the value should be close
to zero background may be due to light
scatter crossed by contaminant particles
air bubbles or by precipitates in the
sample the same effect comes from a
dirty cuvette or cubed shaft or lower
liquid level and the cubed which can
lead to a meniscus in the height of the
night beam absorb it at 320 nano meter
indicates a contamination and is a hint
that the measured concentration is not
correct background values pretend a
higher concentration of the sample and
falsify purity ratios additionally
contamination flight microbial growth
can expect downstream acts reactions
negatively for relatively low background
readings you can just activate the
background correction this will correct
all relevant data by simple subtraction
if higher values then approximately
opened or three are seen you should have
a closer look on your date sample in
order to find the reason for light
scattering often a simple centrifugation
step removing air bubbles or the
resource Panjal of sample precipitates
is sufficient sometimes further
purification of the sample may be
necessary in order to avoid an influence
on downstream applications
now now we come to the purity ratios in
advance I would like to say that
different values are found in the
literature regarding purity ratios of
pure nucleic acid samples one
explanation for this fact is that
samples are used which are resolved in
different buffers and the pH value of
the buffer has an influence on the ratio
on the other hand ratios from literature
ril ones and there are other samples
like body fluids or soil samples which
will never meet these values so the
ratios are helpful for determining the
quality but they will not replace your
own rating on sample quality resulting
from your experience the most common
purity check for DNA and RNA is the
ratio of measurements at 260 and 280
nanometer since proteins have a maximum
absorbance at 280 nanometer for DNA
erasure of 81.8 to 1.9 indicates a good
level purity whereas an hour and a
sample is considered pure for a ratio at
one point nine to two point oh this is
due to its higher ratio of uracil in RNA
as compared to timing which is a
component and DNA lower values indicate
impurities from proteins as well as from
aromatic compounds like see no which
shows an absorbance peak at to 170
nanometer a number of substances absorb
at 230 nanometer as this is the region
of absorbance of peptide bonds aromatic
side chains carbohydrates car tropics
olds or organic solvents values between
2 and 2.5 for the ratio to 160 to 200
turkey are typical for a pure sample
besides solid contaminants different
solubles may be folded sample solutions
to sources are the central matrix with
proteins as main contaminant but they
are also carbohydrate from plant
material or gimmick acids from soil
samples in additional traces of reagents
used during the isolation of nucleic
acids are found typical examples are
phenol and thoughts like gtc the purity
ratios are used as an indicator in order
to decide if the isolated nucleic acids
appear enough to be used in downstream
applications especially organic solvents
and high salt concentrations can shell
inhibitory in FX which lower the
efficiency of genotyping experiments
auditor inspection of sensitive cells
also important is the fact that these
contaminants are dropped at 260
nanometer to and will lead to an
overestimation of nucleic acid
concentration
the contaminants are proteins on the one
hand and thoughts like gtc which are
used for the isolation process as seen
by the DNA spectra and in the table a
typical indicator for protein
contamination is a lower ratio 262 280
together with a strong reduction of 262
230 values when only to 160 to 230 value
zero contaminants like gtcr the course I
have mentioned before that blank
measurements are necessary to subtract
the absorbance from cubed and solvent
some sample measurement therefore it is
important to use exactly the same
solvent for blank advice for sample the
images on this slide show what happens
to the DNA spectro then different
solvents for blankets lville sample have
been used in the first example water was
taken as blank solution and tris buffer
was the sample seulement in the second
example the solutions were used as versa
we see a high impact on the spectra
which of our way from a normal DNA
absorbance spectrum as well as on the
purity oratius 262 230 in the first
example additionally the ratio 260 280
is slightly increased whereas the second
example shares the sample concentration
which really more than twice as high as
the real value from this result you see
that it is extremely important to use
the same solution for blank as for the
sample work performed on this slide I
have summarized different purity ratio
combinations with typical reasons
leading to this effect together with
recommendations how to handle them if
both ratios are low probably
contaminations with proteins or traces
of
aromatic compounds like see no other
reason if required the nucleic acid can
be purified for example by phenyl
chloroform extraction if proteins are
available or by chloroform in order to
remove phenol researches of salts
organic solvents and carbohydrates have
only an effect on the ratio a 262 8 240
which is reduced also these components
can be removed by further purification
in case of excessive salt content for
example an alcohol or precipitation is
appropriate different effect I've seen
if the blank and sample solvents are not
the same if the blank consists of tris
buffer and DNA was softened water is
strong crees of the ratio a 262 a 230th
seen the other way alone will show a
slight increase of 262 280 whereas a 262
a 230 is too low the lord to achieve
reasonable results same solutions have
to be used if the sense of solvent is
not known it may be required to
precipitate and resource the sample if
high moles of RNA contaminated DNA
sample only the ratio a 262 a 280 is
slightly increased and rnase digestion
will help in this case also fluorescence
spectrometry can be a solution in many
cases in order to achieve accurate
results some
times the finger measurement will not
reveal any problems at first sight but
when you read a sample amount of the
times you see different results such
fluctuating values can be induced by
particles in the air bubbles as well as
by a drift of the pH value however the
most important reason is unsur fishing
mixing after resuspension or dilution
steps which lead to in homogeneous
solutions the figure demonstrates that
mixing the surfer carefully is very
important in order to receive reliable
results for this experiment ten
microliter of DNA solution have been
added to ninety microliter buffer
measurements are repeated every five
seconds it is obvious that no mixing
results in a heater or genius solution
but even after three times to spending
with a pipette the readings differ a lot
on the other hand it is shown that
vortexing is very effective in order to
achieve stable and reliable readings
besides careful mixing the qubit has to
be checked for air bubbles and if
possible a slightly alkaline buffer
should be used as a sample solvent in
order to avoid pH shift now we come to
the third Pole and it would be great if
you can give us your answer about how
often you face problems in nucleic acid
quantification
so from the result we see that only four
percent never faced problems whereas
seventy sixty percent Raleigh and twenty
percent and counter frequently problems
now I would like to come to the last
part of my talk which covers the
workflow and a short summary when
setting up a photometric experiment it
is recommended to use a calibrated
pipette with corresponding tips in order
to ensure that dilutions are prepared
correctly for blank and sample the same
solvent has to be used suitable is a
slightly alkaline buffer lectures since
also the pH value can affect sample
readings avoid delusions higher than 1
to 50 since they result in a higher
error probability after dilution
carefully mix the sample it required in
combination with a short centrifugation
step accurate which is used for
photometric Netherlands has to be clean
and intact generally this is given for
disposable qubits but when using quartz
cuvettes take care to clean them
carefully and check on the regular basis
for scratches for measuring playing
assets you read transparency is of
course a prerequisite but also make sure
that the light path hate corresponds
with the light beam head of a photometer
all wavelengths are important for
determine the concentration and inform
about the purity of the nucleic acid
sample nevertheless a complete spectrum
can provide additional information
regarding potential errors in the
handling or contaminants when
programming the photometer have a look
on the following settings the path
lengths of the queue that you take the
rid of your results and the right sector
according to your nucleic acid samples
or evaluation of the quality purity
ratios as well as background absorbance
are informative even sure that the
minimum volume required for the cubit
type is used it is advisable to take
away some microliter in excess in order
to avoid a meniscus affect not only
large air bubbles like the ones shown on
the picture also smaller ones which are
not visible at first glance can
influence the reading therefore check
always blank as well as simple solution
for air bubbles prior to measurement
after reading the sample it is important
to evaluate our results first and most
important point is whether absorbance
values are within the linear range of
the photometer and look for background
at 320 nanometer low values up to
approximately 0 point 0 3 may be
protected that means they are subtracted
from all other results if the absorbance
is higher it is advisable to look for
the cause of background absorbance if
these two parameters are fine have a
look on the purity ratios and optionally
the spectrum as I have said before be
aware that the purity ratios from
literature are ideal ones and they may
not meet met in every case you have to
define your own exacta bill range
depending on the cellphone matrix and
the requirements of your applications it
can also be helpful to check by multiple
measurement of the sample that no drift
or fluctuating values or cure this is
now the last
light of my presentation with a short
summary of the present quotient be aware
about the requirements of your
downstream application regarding the
concentration and purity of of the
nucleic acid sample this does not only
affect the choice of the purification
method but also the decision of the
method for quantification questions to
think about are the expected
concentration and potential contaminants
which can lead to increased readings or
may have an influence on follow-up
reactions for the quantification the
following procedure is reasonable the
setup has to be done carefully with
regard to pipetting accuracy and mixing
the appropriate equipment consisting of
device and cubed has to be chosen
programming of parameters and measuring
of blank and samples have to be done in
the right way and last but not least
evaluation of results according to the
sequence presented before is helpful so
thank you very much for your attention
we have now look on your questions and
we'll start one for them in the
following session questions we cannot
cover today will be answered later via
email in the meantime you may have a
look on the last poll where you can
raise the content of this webinar I
thank you in advance for your feedback
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green two and a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can first
question is what can I do if I don't
know in which buffer my sample has been
solved yeah if your
hi concentrated sample I will generate a
dilution with the defined buffer and
measure the solution into that then the
effect of the original buffer may be
negligible otherwise trying about far
which is commonly used in your lap or
eluding or in spending samples may be
reasonable in this case I would
recommend to check the complete spectrum
is it looks fine you can assume that the
right buffer was found if the results
are not satisfying the best way will of
course be too precise the sample and
resuspended again what is the difference
between light path and light half-height
the light path height of a photometer
indicate the height at which the light
beam of the photometer passes the cubit
so it is important at the life of height
of a photometer at the height of the
optical window logical chevette match to
each other on the other hand the light
path or light path lengths of cuvettes
is a measure for the traveling distance
of the leg to the sample and you have to
set this parameter in the photometer so
that you can get correct measuring
results how does ethanol effect the
change of the absorbance spectrum of
nucleic acids ethanol shows a peak which
is near to 270 nanometer this can lead
to a slight shift of the absorbance
spectrum to us to speak but only if
there are very high contamination I have
observed so far significant effects with
only traces of ether no next person says
it happens sometimes should i see a
negative absorbance what can be the
cause for it and yes
cannot cure when the blank measurement
has a higher absorbent than the sample
solution a very common reason for it our
mix-up of blankets up a solution or a
dirty cubed which is used for the blank
also air bubble to the blank can lead to
such negative sample values if you
explain again why there are different
factors for different types of nucleic
acids are yes of course the absorbance
coefficient epsilon is defined by the
optical behavior of his substance other
specific wavelengths nucleic acids have
a similar structure but they are not
identical the base years ill for example
which we find an RNA has a different
structure than timing which is the
component in DNA also double-stranded
molecules and finger stranded molecules
absorb light in a different way and this
is the reason why we have different
values for absolute and resulting
different factors for RNA
single-stranded and double-stranded DNA
while you recommend a correction for
background values up to point o street
but not for higher values this is
because an absorbent up to all point 0 3
is relatively low but nonetheless
significant a correction of the
measuring wavelength will improve the
accuracy of results the concentration as
well as the purity ratios this will of
course work for higher values too but
there is also high risk that potential
contaminants will affect downstream
reactions negatively and from this
reason it is advisable to look for the
cause of the background if higher values
of cure this is better than just
correcting the values
then you get accurate results with
absorbance measurements I'm sorry hang
on one second can you get accurate
results with absorbance measurements
only or is it better to perform a
fluorescence measurement in addition I
have shown in the presentation that both
methods have their advantages and of
course their disadvantages if you have a
very pure sample with a concentration
resulting in values in the linear range
of the photometer you can receive very
reliable data with an absorbance
measurement but on the other hand if the
concentration is too low only
fluorescence is useful and can be used
however in many cases can be helpful to
perform both types of measurements
especially if you need to know if the
samples pure enough for your downstream
reaction and if you need a very accurate
determination of the concentration I
would once again like to thank Natasha
advice for her presentation do you have
any final comments for us so I would
also say thank you again for your
intention for your questions and as I've
said before we will take care for
answering all your questions via email
after the webinar thanks again thank you
i would also like to thank our sponsor
eppendorf for making today's educational
webcast possible and as Natasha said if
we didn't have time to get your question
today we'll be sure to follow up with
you today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
boots alerting me when this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
may have missed today's live event do
next time bye